viele wollen sich im urlaub engagieren
nicht immer ist das ein erfolg
es gibt programme bei denen freiwillige
bäume pflanzen und dann werden die
wieder ausgegraben damit die nächsten
sie wieder einpflanzen können
manche haben mehr glück ich erlebe doch
hier wunderbare realität ich lerne das
leben können sie vielfalt kennen die
welt so tickt wenn es gut läuft dann
kann freiwilligenarbeit ein richtiges
abenteuer sein
mit mega spannend finde das einfach mal
durch die straßen zu fahren am besten da
wo es keinen grund gibt die schlechten
desto besser der urlaub besser reisen
ist möglich aber wie findet man die
richtige reise
[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens in der
südafrikanischen weg nist 3 4 und 5 ja
irgendwo im dickicht seine das funk
halsband eines nashorns ein signal aus
thomas hanz aus cuxhaven hat seine
familie nach südafrika eingeladen als
freiwillige wollen sie ihren beitrag für
bedrohte tierarten leisten erhalten weiß
er dass die vom aussterben bedroht
managerin pepper open betreut die
familie und freut sich über die
unterstützung ihrer arbeit
das geräusch dass ihr da hört ist in
ruhe signal
der peiner sagt uns dass das tier sich
gerade nicht bewegt das nashorn bleibt
unsichtbar familie hans wert weiter zur
nächsten station ihrer tagesroutine was
auf den ersten blick wie eine ganz
normale safari wirkt ist in wirklichkeit
ein freiwilligendienst für das überleben
der afrikanischen tierwelt thomas hanz
seine frau swetlana und ihre söhne harry
und alex haben dafür zwei wochen ihres
jahresurlaubs geopfert und viel geld
bezahlt das ist ein wasserloch
hier kommen regelmäßig viele tiere
vorbei im moment ist kein signal zu
hören
vor jedem aussteigen muss überprüft
werden ob gefährliche tiere in der nähe
sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie wichtig solche sicherheitsmaßnahmen
sind demonstrieren frische fußspuren am
rande des wasserloch halten augen und
ohren offen und achtet auf spuren noch
vor kurzem waren hier lösen
die spannung ist rundum schauen ist
aufregend mich ich fühle mich lebendig
ich finde das schön
vorsichtig nähert sich die gruppe der
fest installierten kamera einer
sogenannten fotofalle auf der anderen
seite überall lauern gefahren
[Musik]
kunst also letztlich mal war halt ein
skorpion drin und er muss man halt
aufpassen wenn man die kamera
herausholen das man halt nicht von dem
gestochen
diesmal hat sich nur eine harmlose
eidechse versteckt familie hans wechselt
die speicherkarte aus später müssen sie
auswerten welche tiere wand fotografiert
wurden wichtige daten für die arbeit der
ranger ein rosa tiere sind scheu und
diese kameras beobachten speziell breit
mal und spitzmaulnashörner sie zeichnen
dinge auf die wir nie sehen datum zeit
was die tiere machen
bis jetzt hat familie hans noch kein
einziges großes wildes tier gesehen
[Musik]
im norden afrikas verbringt ein
deutscher seinen urlaub ganz anders wir
müssen diese pflanze gesund ja wir
müssen sie gießen eigentlich betreibt
einen eigenen bauernhof bei wiesbaden
jetzt nichts der studierte landwirt
seinen urlaub um als experte eine
biofarm in marokko rentabel zu machen
und zwar mit gehandicapten angestellten
meine zwei hauptaufgaben 4
das ist einmal konzepte zu entwickeln
wie wir menschen mit beeinträchtigungen
im agrarbereich integrieren können als
vollwertige mitarbeiter und der zweite
bereich ist im bereich landwirtschaft so
mehr ökologische aspekte reinzubekommen
im gegensatz zur familie hans reiff
sharp für seinen urlaub nichts bezahlen
er bekommt sogar kosten sie umsonst
dafür sind die erwartungen an den
freiwilligen aus dem ausland hoch der
sozialpädagoge hamberg ii hat den
integrationsbetrieb mit aufgebaut
von ralf schaab erhofft er sich
unterstützung bei der qualifikation der
mitarbeiter
[Musik]
wir können es uns nicht erlauben unser
wissen nicht immer wieder auf den
neuesten stand zu bringen
deswegen sind wir sehr dankbar dass
doktor ralf uns hilft die fähigkeiten
der jungen menschen so zu schulen dass
sie irgendwann auf dem normalen
arbeitsmarkt eine chance haben außerdem
soll die farm endlich schwarze zahlen
schreiben nicht nur bei den hühnern
denn die ernte blieb bislang mager
vielleicht ist die erde nicht fruchtbar
genug deshalb bereitschaft zeigen wie
man einen ökologisch wertvollen
komposthaufen errichtet das hier ist der
miss das organische material was wir für
unseren kompass brauchen um den
aufzuwerten mit nährstoffen
komposthaufen
das ist für viele hin dass der
promovierte agrarwissenschaftler gerade
hier in seinem urlaub freiwilligen
dienst leistet ist kein zufall
auf seinem biohof in deutschland
beschäftigt er selbst menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen
deshalb wurde er als experte ausgewählt
möglich macht das ganze der senior
expert service
dort können sich interessierte auf einer
webseite registrieren
betriebe aus dem ausland die hilfe
brauchen bekommen vom ses geeignete
experten vorgeschlagen
ursprünglich war das modell nur für
ruheständler konzipiert mittlerweile
werden aber auch berufstätige vermittelt
die gast organisation zahlt nur den
unterhalt vor ort ein honorar bekommt
der experte nicht für reichart kein
problem ich bin doch hier ja ich erlebe
doch hier wunderbar realität ich lerne
das leben kennen sie vielfalt kennen wie
die welt so tickt das lerne ich hier
kennen müssen ganz großes geschenk für
mich
[Musik]
früher wären ralf schaaf schützlinge in
marokko von ihren eltern versteckt
worden
geistige behinderung galt lange als
strafe von bösen geistern die menschen
zu integrieren und ihnen arbeit zu geben
das ist neu und trägt jetzt schon
früchte
[Musik]
wir machen das um geld zu verdienen und
um unsere eltern zu unterstützen
ich habe zb in meiner mutter diana die
kleine pilgerfahrt finanzieren können
da war sie zusammen mit mir meiner
schwester und meinen beiden tanten
bislang zahlt eine stiftung des
marokkanischen königs alle gehälter die
vision eines echten biohofs ist kaum
umgesetzt freistaat glaubt zu wissen
woran das liegt hier bei der arbeit die
darin dass die obrigkeit gerne einen
sauberen garten haben möchte und das ist
natürlich contra jeglicher jeglichen
ökologie gedanken
denn ein öko hof braucht zum
funktionieren biologische vielfalt
langweiliger rasen passt nicht in dieses
konzept
deshalb lässt ralf schaab die
mitarbeiter kurzerhand ein loch buddeln
seine idee wilde blumen sollen insekten
anlocken die wiederum schädlinge
auffressen
ein grundpfeiler des biolandbaus
gleichzeitig aber auch hübsch genug für
eine königliche stiftung jetzt haben wir
alles hier in die feuchte erde gesetzt
jetzt brauchen wir aber noch wasser um
das alles an zu gießen
zwei wochen bleibt ralf schaab in
marokko
danach wird er sich wieder um seinen
eigenen bauernhof kümmern
bis zum nächsten arbeitseinsatz im
urlaub also diese arbeit im ausland ist
eigentlich als integraler bestandteil
von meinem leben ja das würde ich die
nächsten 20 jahre hoffentlich noch ganz
viel energie machen können und dass es
halt bereichernd und natürlich gar nicht
mehr wegdenken
am ende seines aufenthalts hat reis
sharp gemeinsam mit den einheimischen
einen entwicklungsplan für den öko hof
erarbeitet in einem halben jahr will er
zurückkehren und schauen ob er als
experte wieder gebraucht wird
[Musik]
doch nicht nur profis wie sharp sondern
auch jüngere menschen ohne lange
berufserfahrung können ihr wissen in die
welt tragen
[Musik]
wie das funktionieren kann lässt sich in
einem berliner hinterhof erlernen
die 32-jährige greta hole hat das
seminar konzipiert die zukünftigen
volunteers sollen erst mal locker werden
die kursteilnehmer sollen erleben was es
heißt im mittelpunkt zu stehen als
sogenannte tisch surfer möchten sie im
urlaub workshops halten in der regel auf
englisch was hier deshalb auch
arbeitssprache ist
[Musik]
greta hat das prinzip miterfunden tief
surfing so heißt auch das start up das
sich vor drei jahren mit einer freundin
gründete jeder mensch hat etwas
unglaublich wertvoll ist also jeder von
uns weiß so viel und wir laufen halt
durch die gegend und denken wir brauchen
für alles in ausbildung und ein
zertifikat
aber wir lernen so viel miteinander und
voneinander und das hat sie auf ihrer
internetplattform professionalisiert
dort werden für die surfer weltweit
workshops vermittelt die dauernd oft nur
wenige stunden und sind für die
teilnehmer kostenlos die idee menschen
vor ort mit neuem wissen zu inspirieren
und das im urlaub
du hast uns aus der komfortzone heraus
geholt meint felix kiefer aus gießen
auch er möchte als tipp surfer losziehen
der 27 jährige student plant einen trip
nach serbien
ich würde gerne weil ich auch gerne
unterricht würde ich das gerne mal mit
einer reise verbinden und mal gucken
erspielte sich daher aus dem ausland an
um da so direkteinstieg in die kultur zu
bekommen in sechs wochen soll es
losgehen
mit einem programmierer workshop im
gepäck will der student der
elektrotechnik dann andere junge
menschen inspirieren und wenn es gut
läuft den einheimischen auch näher
kommen
[Musik]
familie hans hat immer noch kein
einziges größeres tier in freier
wildbahn gesehen
jetzt hoffen die freiwilligen auf die
bilder aus der fotofalle
das ist das baby das ich gesucht hatte
ein junges spitzmaulnashorn wie alt ist
es circa zwei monate zwei monate aber
die mutter hat es versteckt um es zu
schützen die uns deswegen hatten wir
bisher noch keine fotos von ihm
deshalb sind die kameras so wichtig der
bestand aller tiere im reservat soll so
eng wie möglich überwacht werden sowohl
mit kamera fallen als auch über
funksignale diese arbeit leisten
freiwillige dafür hat jeder von ihnen
rund 1300 euro bezahlt das bin ja ich
dass dieses geld sinnvoll verwendet wird
war für familie hans extrem wichtig
deshalb wählten sie ein programm mit
bedrohten tieren in afrika das mit dem
sogenannten fair trade tourismus
zertifikat ausgezeichnet wurde
[Musik]
george hat das siegel mitentwickelt
heute besucht sie das zum kann da
reservat um die einhaltung der strengen
kriterien zu kontrollieren
[Musik]
wie lange seid ihr schon hier schon
etwas länger
wir sind letzte woche angekommen am
montag oder wir bleiben zwei wochen
unzählige programme werden unter dem
schlagwort vallon tourismusangeboten
match hat diesen markt jahre lang
studiert und weiß wie oft der gute wille
der freiwilligen missbraucht wird
es gibt programme wo freiwillige bäume
pflanzen und dann werden die wieder
ausgegraben damit die nächsten sie
wieder einpflanzen können
ein anderes negativ beispiel in asien
dort hat sich aufgrund der großen
nachfrage ein regelrechter wohl und
tourismusmarkt gebildet mit zum teil
skrupellosen methoden
manchmal werden kinder als angebliche
weisen in heime gesteckt damit zahlen
der freiwillige ihnen englisch
unterricht geben können
auch südafrika hat sich einen schlechten
ruf erworben mit sogenannten löwen auf
zuchtfarmen in denen freiwillige mit
tiger und löwen babys kuscheln dürfen
ein so an den menschen gewöhnt ist hier
wird in safari parks zur leichten beute
für tufan jäger
anders im sommer games hier sorgen die
verantwortlichen dafür dass das geld der
volunteers nicht nur den wilden tieren
nutzt sondern auch den menschen vor ort
expertin jane es lässt sich die anlage
zeigen wir versorgen nicht nur das wild
im reservat mit wasser sondern auch die
ortschaften drum herum redet auch mit
den angestellten und überprüft ob die
siegel kriterien eingehalten werden
hier schaffen wolle und tier ist mit
ihrem geld auch neue jobs mit fairen
löhnen oft passiert aber das gegenteil
deshalb rät allen interessierten
freiwilligen sich vor ihrer entscheidung
intensiv zu informieren
woher weiß man dass das geld wirklich
zum umweltschutz beiträgt und das nicht
nur behauptet wird man muss seine
hausaufgaben machen den gastgeber im
vorfeld viele fragen stellen und nach
einem glaubwürdigen label suchen wonach
die organisation überprüft und
zertifiziert ist
bislang ist fairtrade touristen das
einzige siegel in afrika das auch wollen
tourismus programme auszeichnet bei
angeboten ohne siegel sollten
interessierte deshalb folgende kriterien
selbst überprüfen
gute projekte sind sozial verantwortlich
dienen den menschen vor ort
sie sind umweltgerecht gut für tiere und
umwelt und wie das geld verwendet wird
muss vollkommen transparent sein
so wie in sung kang der reservat fast
täglich kommen zum beispiel schulklassen
hier her um im naturkunde unterrichtet
zu werden
auch das wird mit dem geld der
volunteers finanziert mit dem geld das
sie bezahlen kann unser dorf zum
beispiel ausflüge ins reservat
finanzieren
das ist eine gute sache mit dem geld
luxus gibt es für die freiwilligen nicht
familie hans wohnt in einem karg
ausgestatteten container sie kochen ihr
eigenes essen machen den abwasch und
haben trotzdem gut
ich mag auch jetzt immer noch gerne
städtereisen machen und was ich auf das
geht schon gerne machen aber sowas ist
hier ist etwas besonderes das kriegt man
nicht alle tage
und vielleicht werden sie ja doch noch
ein paar große wilde tiere zu gesicht
bekommen
das hoffen sie immer noch
[Musik]
felix kiefer hat sich tatsächlich als
teachers den weg gemacht
in belgrad hat er über die
internetplattform einem gastgeber
gefunden mit im gepäck ein workshop über
das programmieren von mikroprozessoren
aber vor allem geht es felix auch und
das intensive eintauchen in eine fremde
welt
ich bin mega spannend in fremden ländern
einfach mal durch die straßen zu fahren
durch hexen fahren zu können wo
vielleicht nicht so viele touristen
unterwegs sind am besten da wo es kein
lidl und aldi mehr gibt und da fühle ich
mich wo die straßen je schlechter desto
besser der urlaub für mich in der
innenstadt von belgrad trifft felix
seinen gastgeber david
[Musik]
oft organisieren die gastgeber im rahmen
des titels irvings auch eine
übernachtungsmöglichkeit
doch felix schläft lieber im eigenen
wohnmobil für frühstücks tipps ist er
allerdings dankbar gastgeber david für
den tipp schärfer aus deutschland in
eine bäckerei zum frühstück gibt es hier
allerdings keinen kaffee sondern bis zum
workshop bleibt noch etwas zeit zum
essen führt david seinen gast deshalb
auf eine aussichtsplattform mit blick
auf die stadt
auch das gehört zum typ surfen besondere
tipps zu bekommen die nicht im
reiseführer stehen super-g gespannt wie
es weiter geht
ich bin jetzt bald gibt's den workshop
ich hoffe dass andere auch alles so
klappt
die veranstaltung findet in einem
gebäude der technischen universität
statt
rund ein dutzend teilnehmer haben sich
angemeldet die meisten von ihnen
studieren informatik
ich würde mich riesig freuen wenn ich es
schaffen würde noch mal zu motivieren
das was wir heute machen mich ein
bisschen programmieren und bis wir uns
mit der materie beschäftigen wenn das
vielleicht noch nach für den anfang
seines workshops hat sich felix eine
besondere aktion ausgedacht
ich bin felix kiefer bevor wir anfangen
machen wir einen warmup bitte steht auf
und stellt euch hier in die mitte wenn
das geht in der vorbereitung hat felix
gelernt wie wichtig es ist sein publikum
gleich am anfang wachzurütteln
in deiner hand werde ich die
morsezeichen für einen buchstaben tippen
felix spielt stelle post nicht mit
flüstern sondern mit dem morse alphabet
nach anfänglichem zögern macht es den
studenten spaß
das eis ist gebrochen der workshop kann
beginnen
jeder teilnehmer bekommt einen eigenen
mikroprozessor schritt für schritt
erklärt felix wie sich solch ein mini
computer programmieren ist
am ende signalisiert das blinken der
leuchtdioden es hat geklappt felix hat
seine zuhörer nicht nur erreicht er hat
sie tatsächlich inspiriert es ist selten
dass jemand einfach kommt und fragt hey
willst du etwas von mir leid ich habe
freie zeit den willen und das wissen
möchtest du kommen zu hören es ist eine
einzigartige erfahrung
normalerweise lerne ich viel theorie
aber das hier ist er praktisch anders
als ich es gewohnt bin
es macht mir spaß spät am abend feiert
felix mit gastgeber david seinen ersten
auftritt als server erleichtert müde und
zufrieden
ich will auf jeden fall wenn ich mal
wieder einen job mache großen
organisation auf den weg gibt wo ich
tipp surfen kann welches auf jeden fall
noch mal machen
mehr als 2.000 freiwillige haben sich
mittlerweile auf der plattform
registriert um ihr wissen in die welt zu
tragen
[Musik]
volunteer einsätze sind aber auch in
deutschland möglich zb bei der mangold
ernte auf einem bio-bauernhof will frey
dieser sorte benutzt man beim kochen das
ganze blatt
wisst ihr wie man spinat zubereitet man
schneidet das ganz klar
mangold ist nicht sehr bekannt in
amerika oder kanada oder nein nur ein
bisschen für gemüse begeisterte lernen
indem man bei der arbeit hilft das ist
das motto beim sogenannten looping auch
jacob weiß aus baltimore arbeitet ohne
geld dafür zu bekommen
seit sieben uhr morgens ist er auf den
beinen und es macht ihm großen spaß
ich bin jetzt seit drei wochen dar und
bleibe noch zwei wochen also insgesamt
fünf wochen
eigentlich wollte ich nur zwei wochen
bleiben aber mir gefällt der bauernhof
so gut dass ich verlängert aber bio
bauer markus uhlenbrock enes bietet seit
sechs jahren fing an
vor allem während der ernte dafür muss
er regelmäßig neue freiwillige einweisen
die leute die jetzt hier zu uns auf dem
hof kommen die haben im prinzip null
vorerfahrung die haben also kommen
meistens aus der stadt von dem er
erkläre ich das gerne immer wieder und
wieder und das ist das einfach das was
dazugehört hat wenn man hoch war auch
auf dem hof beschäftigt bis zu 80
verleben in der hochsaison auf dem
ehrenhof sie arbeiten vier bis sechs
stunden pro tag
dafür sind kost und logis frei den
kontakt zur öko bauern finden wir über
eine plattform im internet und bei der
feldarbeit lernen sie dazu zum beispiel
dass gestreift auberginen besonders gut
schmecken
guck dir diese wunderschöne lila an
das ist nicht lila er nennt das graffiti
oder nicht weißt du dass diese die
leckersten sind schmelzen im mund die
sind viel besser als die lilafarbenen
die 23-jährige gewinnes aus wales hat
schon zum zweiten mal als souverän auf
dem eulenhof angeheuert obwohl sie
unbezahlt arbeitet fühlt sie sich kein
bisschen ausgenutzt wir haben hier einen
wunderschönen ort zum leben und das
ganze tolle essen
alles was wir ernten dürfen wir auch
essen ich finde das ist ein sehr fairer
tausch
ein fairer deal kritiker mahnen das mofa
jobs machen die auch von arbeitslosen
erledigt werden könnten
landwirtin ulrike enes hält dagegen
diese art von engagement sagt sie sei
über das arbeitsamt nicht zu bekommen
also ich denke ein euro jobber da fehlt
mir die motivation in der regel und die
ufer machen das komplett freiwillig in
ihrer freizeit ein-euro-jobber müssen
arbeiten und das muss fällt hier weg in
entwicklungsländern allerdings sieht die
lage oft anders aus manche mohns hausen
hat sich viele jahre mit dem thema wohl
und tourismus beschäftigt und zwei
studien dazu veröffentlicht moving in
deutschland findet sie unproblematisch
wer in die ferne will sollte aber
kritisch hinterfragen ob sein guter
wille nicht vielleicht doch auch
negative auswirkungen hat es ist eine
riesige herausforderung dass es
natürlich eine konkurrenz gibt zwischen
arbeitskräften vororten anstellung
suchen und freiwilligen die kostenfrei
ihre dienste anbieten also ich hab es in
guatemala selber lebt wie auf einem buch
in hof die freiwilligen kostenfrei
gearbeitet haben und an der straße die
tagelöhner standen und arbeit suchten
für einen tag oder für eine woche das
geht natürlich gar nicht der
freiwilligen arbeit leistet muss also
genau hinsehen egal ob der einsatz
unbezahlt ist wie bei den rufen oder die
volunteers teuer dafür bezahlen dass sie
überhaupt arbeiten dürfen
[Musik]
so wie familie hans in südafrika mehr
als 5000 euro haben sie für ihren
zweiwöchigen aufenthalt ausgegeben
dafür hoffen sie heute einen höhepunkt
zu erleben
sie versuchen ganz nah an eine löwen
familie heranzukommen
ein weibchen hat sich vor einiger zeit
verletzt
ranger in pepper möchte wissen wie es
der löwen mittlerweile geht okay leute
welchen baum wollen wir nehmen die tiere
sollen mit futter angelockt werden
eine tote der zelle wird als köder an
einen baum festgekettet
alex ziehst du hier mal danke mit dem
paul gerät kontrolliert thomas hanz wie
weit die löwen entfernt sind
mittlerweile scheinen sie den geruch
gewitter zu haben
die ranger rennpferd den jeep in eine
sichere entfernung zum köder nach
wenigen minuten erscheint der erste live
da ja welche richtung der löwe wirkt
entspannt scheint die zuschauer nicht zu
beachten und dreht wieder ab für familie
hans der ersten kontakt zu einem großen
wildtier dann reicht das schon als
genugtuung für mich auf jeden fall klar
gerade wenn man das gern die ganze zeit
wirklich
gestern fand eine erste löwen nähert
sich dem köder sie ist noch nicht das
tier um das sich die ranger in sorgen
macht
doch es dauert nicht lange bis das ist
sie die zweite löwen die haben wir
gesucht
thomas hanz macht für die ranger in
fotos der löwen geht es gut
genauso wie ihren babys das angehen dass
auch sie das ist glücklich sind die
tiere den plan das gut geht
ich hatte genug gesehen aber so was
nicht jedem volunteer ist eine solche
erfahrung vergönnt doch selbst wenn ein
aufenthalt keine so spannenden
highlights bietet ist der ranger rinn
eines besonders wichtig dass die
freiwilligen ihre begeisterung für die
sache mit nach haus nehmen
wir wollen ja jeder freiwillige den wir
hier inspirieren können geht zurück in
sein heimatland als botschafter
vielleicht sammeln sie spenden der
rekrutieren neue freiwillige oder sie
verändern etwas im alltag um einen
beitrag zur rettung gefährdeter tiere zu
leisten
obwohl familie hans nur zwei wochen zeit
hatte konnten sie für das reservat
einiges leisten
sie haben hunderte von fotos ausgewertet
zäune repariert und fahrwege von
gestrüpp befreit und sie wissen dass ihr
geld tatsächlich für den artenschutz
verwendet wird
[Musik]